[Music]
your busy guy but they're offering you a
lot of reality shows is that true I get
it with every single reality show you
know dance with the Stars you've got
thanks for the stuff Oracle is our co
really a star now i think i think they
should call it dancing with ex
celebrities who didn't save their money
[Laughter]
have you seen celebrity ghost stories
no I haven't seen over two ghost stories
where celebrities go on and they talk
about that they've seen ghosts yeah like
a hundred celebrities have seen ghosts
they also happy to pay you $6,000 now
they offered it to me if I would have
seen a ghost I guess I would have done
it but the thing that gets me these
celebrities that have seen the ghost
don't seem to be working that much you
know what I mean George Clooney doesn't
see ghosts Brad Pitt doesn't see ghosts
Meryl Streep and the dick sir goes
to me Jackson chose Oh
so wondering if somebody has anything to
do it maybe I'm cynical cause they see
ghosts every week how come there's not
like a hundred bus drivers so now it's
only celebrities all right now you are
hosting a show about real-life hitmen
real-life hitmen this is a fascinating
concept because we're all fascinated by
the whole concept of a hitman hitman
what kind of stories you hearing what
are the some of the good stories we have
a story coming out is a woman a man and
a woman are married for 17 years they're
getting divorce he doesn't want to give
up and I'm telling you the truth he
doesn't want to give up his baseball
card collection in the divorce so he
hires a hit man to kill his wife she's
five foot six to 60 she's a nurse the
hit man's five-eight 180 he's in the
house waiting for her hits her in the
head with a hammer three times they
fight for a half an hour she's on camera
telling you this and she's choking him
she turns the tables she says to him who
sent you and his last words are boy
you're strong
and she's miss to tell the story